hey guys how's it going so a lot of you
guys asked me quite often what iPhone
taste do I have and of course a lot of
you are well aware that I did get the
jet-black iPhone you were confused in a
lot of videos as to why it looked like I
had a matte black iPhone so to start
things off the case that I'm currently
using on my phone is just the basic
silicon case from Apple nothing too
special but the case that you guys
probably saw on my phone and got a
little bit confused is this case it's
inside here called a peeled case this is
not sponsored I'm not gonna say this
case is the reason that I shattered my
phone two times in 24 hours I'm reckless
yes I was holding my dog and I had my
phone and he pulled me and my phone fell
flat on its face now usually with any
other normal cases they have a little
bit of a lip on them so it will kind of
protect your screen a little bit the
peel case is actually some awesome
because it doesn't have a lip on it it
basically just conforms to your iPhone
and it's basically like you have nothing
on it's like your phone is native I got
my screen replaced I put my case back on
and I dropped it so hard that I cracked
the case and also cracked the little
bottom part of my phone here so the only
case that I had left was this black one
that I'd previously been using another
issue that I have is when I'm flying my
DJI Mavic is I can't really fit this
phone plus a case into it and what this
little guy it is so incredibly thin that
it kind of just protects the back of
your screen now if you're reckless I do
not recommend getting this but if you're
not directly then this case is so
perfect they also have a jet black one
too but I wouldn't really recommend you
because it's smudged a lot and it's
scratched a lot I thought they did we've
gotta make my phone look like it was jet
black I did but the matte black heel
case works great clip for instructions
okay
since I have a little accident I saw
that they also had something it's a
glass edge-to-edge screen protector I
haven't tried this out yet but I think
this might solve my problem Oh give me a
little little cloth or an alcohol prep
pad oh yeah good look at that it
basically just looks exactly like your
iPhone so this just goes right on top of
your phones let's assemble the case and
put this on and hopefully I won't crack
without again if you love the plastic
carefully oh gosh okay I'll call it up
prepping up for surgery remove any
remaining dust particles I'm so nervous
I'm not gonna line this up well did I do
a good job looks really good like you
honestly can't even tell if there's
something on here at all it's so good
I'm impressed
no we're gonna put this cover on guess
I'll just use my alcohol pad and clean
the back of this up two slobs I feel
like a combination of both of these
things will alleviate the incident that
happened before I go and this is so fin
like look at this it's crazy out
Fitness's Grandda did not makes my phone
look like it's matte black but you can
hardly even tell that I have anything on
it it's great it looks like my phone
doesn't even cracked anymore here's
gonna be the real test will I be able to
fit this nice and comfortably into the
DJI Mavic controller it still fits quite
well and it's much easier than any of
the other cases so this is cool
good spy we can't have nice things
in this house if it's like look you can
see there's like a little bubble right
there I didn't do a very good job this
stuff is extremely important it's clean
you guys while we're at it I'll keep you
guys posted if you follow me on Twitter
and I just Dean or Instagram I just mean
you don't see me post anything about
shattered iPhones then you will know
that this has been successful yes I'm
very happy it looks great it feels I
mean it's still it's still thinner than
this phone like I can still probably put
my phone inside of this case because
it's so thin so when you guys question
what case I have and why I don't have a
jet-black phone I do I still do have a
jet-black phone it's just it's covered
in the peel case oh this is great I'm
super excited have I said that I think
I've already said it many times well
thank you guys so much for watching I
will put a link in the description where
you guys can check out these cases
they're pretty cool I'm a big fan like I
said I did shadow my phone twice with
them so if that happens to you don't say
it warned you which is why I recommended
getting this glass cover because I feel
like this is gonna really protect your
phone if you do drop it face down like I
did nothing it's foolproof except those
otter boxes because those things are
beyond intense let me know if there's
anything else that's pretty cool that
you guys want me to check out and maybe
I'll check it out I'll see you guys the
next video you have